welcome to this video sofrito it's a new
pony time okay then y'know the Guru
thought so let's not screw up the move
water this time I had a water problem in
the arm felt before that didn't really
am lead to any problem just them but
what do people to really study theory
now it is right there should be six and
that Sam that's some fashionable line
the ideas actually to play c6 now and
then drop it back to see eight and then
not f 57 and e5 yeah let's see if he had
it was for that Bishop c8 now as they
move no stop doing it ok I think I
should develop my setup is a bit slow so
ok so he played the fashionable line
without relief um yeah without really
following the the main idea
at five Wow ok
so yeah I wonder is it an idea to put
something on you five now is that a bet
a bad moment to do it
okay let's lend some support to see five
so that in case of e five okay so a 50
kb five you can actually take on c5
because of that long diagonal it's a bit
awkward hmm ok now I underestimated a
five quite a bit that's it's bad okay
now you can take on before play okay
three that's not very nice
yeah definitely yeah that's not that's
really not what I wanted but I can take
with the deep porn I'm playing this very
badly hmm ok I was somewhat I only
thinking about fgs I don't know why
now very high fat that was spared him
very stupid idea that he should take
with the f porn of course it takes with
the deep on to open up its diagonal of
that bishop on f7 we had sometimes it's
weird the kind of idea set that you have
in a game and just just looking at it
like with a clear head you will clearly
see that f takes is just ridiculous d
takes is so much better laughs that was
bad but ok let's see what is doing
here's a couple of interesting ideas you
can just take you five of course for
being battle
interesting
quindi 48 is very embarrassing hmm
okay I probably have to mix that night
if he takes on e5 I have 27 not that
this is like great but that'sthat's was
my IDM rock d 8 is probably better
anyway
jarek dat looks fairly normal now
anything I wonder have 94 is a move 94
Queenie 590 xe6 Ruby 19 txt five
interesting
not before the idea would be e 6 but it
can be easily can easily backfire that
idea yeah but what else is there i am i
probably have to do it yeah this is of
course may i'm overlooking the simplest
museum and anyway probably right so
Quinn a sound have to get down to play
the problem is that once he gets gets
the Queen away and he will get an e 5
i'm just in in in a sorry state Queen B
6 no that's not working I Scotty
fiscally 5 coming between 8-5 night
coming to over now I cannot even go to
be three yet that's really rotten what a
bad position amazing
it's really amazing how bad this is it's
there probably have no squares it's just
an awful position FYI take onee for at
least but ok it's not going to going to
go out for him is there some some idea
that I have some idea if I go like rook
e1 rook a1 rook a 70 that there could be
an idea to activate a little bit mean is
clearly better maybe winning word at
least he has some problems to solve not
difficult once I mean maybe just rope
this tablet Quincy 7 is an idea this one
what is the idea here not quite sure I
can go look to you one not something
wrong with that yeah okay you can do
that with this is not a huge problem
yeah I have be five now maybe this is a
this is some kind of idea time morning
not is that Quincy 7i can move away yeah
okay let's sets instead okay maybe I
mean relatively speaking this one okay
for luke t 1 let's see so let's move the
night away rook a7 now see I don't get
it that I can take now it's good to see
that it happens to to my opponents as
well that they all play me and I win
with a cheap tactical shot that's the
way I usually usually lose but it was
just a bad bad performance by me a
couple of with life require fats on time
really bad ideas yeah it was interesting
that that way of playing here with my
dear five so have my doubts but it's
it's the way I played it it was very
justified before already was a bad bad
move probably I it's interesting the
engine actually wants to play this and
doesn't mind this kind of thing
interesting yeah that's interesting I
might have compensation here I get in a
trade here this weekend after nights if
I the deaths compensation the engine
actually it says white is better but i'm
not sure but its compensation okay
that's much better I mean I knew that
this wasn't great i just thought that
there wasn't any any decent alternative
and this is just plain idiotic out it's
just bad I was only thinking about this
after which 95 is okay I don't ask me UD
takes is just much much better and after
that i'm clearly worse
I mean clearly worse yeah just just bad
just very bad 94 it's all okay meanie
maybe even had some better opportunities
but black is clearly better the way it
went here went here yeah he's just
clearly better the engine gives route 87
and then Quincy sound which is probably
true but I don't think he did anything
wrong up to this this particular point
where he from here where he hey baby
blonde at the piece if you just place
this I mean what am i doing that I
really don't have anything great job
like this for example he can now play it
Jim robot for this my move maybe I have
to have to drop back and continue from
here but it's a pawn it's it just
probably losing the night is in terrible
shape it has no squares just grateful
black yeah that was lucky thanks for
watching